[Music]
gymnastics is one of the most watched
olympic events in america
millions of people tune in to watch
elite athletes twist
flip and launch themselves in the air
we'll take a look at three events to see
how these athletes master the physics to
pull off
epic gymnastic feats hi i'm emily
i'm a physics phd student at yale
university
in my past life i was a level 10 gymnast
physics and gymnastics
really go hand in hand and they're so so
interesting i'm always blown away by how
much
knowledge of physics gymnasts and other
athletes carry in their bodies
it's really amazing to to watch and
think about
[Music]
we're watching leanne wong do a piece of
an uneven bar routine
first skill that she does is called a
van lewin where she releases from the
low bar does a half turn and catches the
high bar
then she does her glide kip she casts up
to a handstand she does two giants which
is that motion where you go from a
handstand and then return back to a
handstand
to pick up speed going into her dismount
two laid out flips with two twists
this is a very difficult skill the
gymnast technique has to be so good in
order for her to get that lift that she
needs to raise her center
mass up enough for her to grip the high
bar this is a little bit more difficult
because it adds this half
twist in she releases the bar with one
hand slightly before the other in doing
so she's applying a torque to the bar
and that's enabling her to get this half
twist something so cool about the bars
is
you have a visible indication like a
nice visual indication
of how forces are at play because the
bar
bends in accordance with those forces
something that is really interesting to
compute in a bar routine
is just the acceleration that she
experiences at the bottom of her giant
swings
i'm making a lot of approximations with
all of these calculations
there's a lot more going on than the
simplified physics that i'm doing but
even so it should start to give you
a bit of a picture of what's going on
and why some of these moves are so
challenging
when she's at this point in her routine
there are two forces acting on her right
here gravity which is pointing downwards
and compounding gravity
she feels what's called a centrifugal
force which is
pulling her away from the bar or pushing
her downwards
centripetal acceleration is equal to v
squared
over r this v squared is for the center
of mass
of something moving around an axis
velocity is distance over time
and distance in this case if she's doing
a giant is the circumference
of a circle traced out by her center of
mass as she goes completely around the
bar the circumference of a circle is
two times pi times the radius and then
this divided by the time it takes for
her to complete that one revolution
and so when we plug in for her distance
to center of mass
we'll call the radius about three feet
because she's about five feet and i
think her full rotation is about one
point
revolution is about 1.7 seconds in the
end
we get velocity equals
roughly 3.4 meters per second
putting this back in our acceleration or
centripetal acceleration v squared over
r plugging in numbers
we get 12.5 meters per second squared
which is roughly equivalent to 1.3
times gravitational acceleration
but as she's doing the swing it's not
just this centripetal force that's
acting on her
there's also gravity as well so the
acceleration that she experiences at the
bottom of her swing
is actually a total
equals the centripetal acceleration plus
acceleration due to gravity and i should
say this only holds when she's at the
very bottom of her swing
and this would be you know 2.3
g's of acceleration that's quite a lot
it's you know you can imagine
hanging off a bar and having something
an extra u
holding on to you and you have to
support that weight so this is this is a
lot of acceleration and correspondingly
a lot of force that lands experiencing
and she's just holding on with her hands
you'll notice when a lot of gymnasts are
learning this skill the most common
place for them to sort of peel off the
bar accidentally let go
is right at this point when they're
moving the fastest and also have these
forces acting on them
oh my gosh bars are my favorite i wish i
had a better answer than they're just so
[Music]
fun
now we're going to take a look at simone
biles on floor the tumbling pass we see
from simone is
called the biles named after her she
does uh
two flips in a laid out position with a
half turn right at the end it's
incredibly difficult and she was the
first one to ever do it
part of what makes the scale so
challenging is that simone is flipping
in a laid out position instead of a tuck
there are physical reasons behind this
and you can use physics equations to
sort of build a picture of why this is
the case so we can model simone here
as uh flipping in her laid out position
as a
as a rod of length l so l is the length
of
her body spinning about some axis of
rotation this will be the energy
of a double layout
will be proportional to the moment of
inertia which
is equal to approximately for a rod
1 12 m l squared
for a double talk we're going to
approximate her as a sphere when she's
tucked
and moment of inertia of a sphere is
two-fifths
m r squared where r if you're
if she's balled up in a sphere we're
going to call r
approximately l over 3. if i tuck myself
up
the radius of my body is about a third
if we want to compare
the energy of a double layout to a
double tuck this is equal to two-fifths
and this will be l over three squared
two-fifths
m l squared over nine we can look at the
ratio
the layout over e-tuck
this is going to be equal to one-twelfth
over 2 over 45. so it's roughly
two times as much energy to complete a
double layout
than a double tuck and this is just
accounting for the energy involved
and not even talking about how precisely
she needs to
be able to place her body in order to do
this skill
and remain so rigid and also get the
height required and the rotation
required
we're looking at new olympian jordan
childs and
in this tumbling pass she's doing a
piked double arabian with a half out
the energy that she winds up with is
built through her run it's built through
these contact points and how she
manipulates her body to interact with
the floor in the springs she's running
here
and then she contacts contacts contacts
and releases to do her skill
an interesting thing to look at with
this tumbling pass is
how much energy is involved i'm going to
be making a lot of approximations in
this calculation
it will not be exact it might even be
off by a factor of two but it should
still give you an idea and some
intuition for how hard what's going on
actually is
we'll need to know her mass 55 kilograms
her height 1.524
meters that just corresponds to five
foot even
we'll also need to know her body's
radius if you're looking directly at
someone from their stomach to their hips
it's an approximation that's going to be
0.15 meters
acceleration due to gravity which is
9.81
meters per second squared this
calculation is a little bit complicated
because it involves her moment of
inertia which is
the rotational analog of her mass and
it's
basically a description of how her mass
is organized
relative to the axis she's rotating
around so we're going to approximate her
twisting
as if she were a rod we're going to talk
about
her in her piped position when she flips
as if she's a disk
that's also going to look like m disc
radius
squared over 2. for twisting and
flipping her full time in the air
is 1.125 seconds the distance
is one half a t squared acceleration is
just acceleration due to gravity
so this will be one half gt squared this
will tell you the distance from her
highest point to when she lands
when she lands she's at a velocity of
zero and taking
t is 1.125
seconds over two since uh the 1.125 was
for her total arc and this is only for
her coming down the 1.52 meters is how
much her center of mass
is raised above its landing point height
above round
equals d plus center of mass
height this is the d we're going to be
taking
and now we can compute her gravitational
potential energy
at this piece so e from gravity
is mass times gravity times height which
i get
here to be 822 joules
we can get the energy of her twist
is equal to one half i
omega squared so i is this um
moment of inertia i was talking about
omega is her rotational velocity so the
how fast she's spinning e flip
will also be one half i
this is twist and i flip
omega squared twist is uh
10 joules and this is 422 joules
the total energy should be equal to the
gravitational energy
plus her energy twisting plus her energy
from flipping
and you get 1274
joules this number to put it in context
is a lot of
a lot of energy for for a a person doing
a jump if a
a person of this mass were to jump a
foot and a half which is about
standard for what american women can
jump
the e of a normal jump would be about
200 joules so 5 to 6 times the energy
of my jump is what jordan is doing here
this calculation that i just did shows
the energy involved in
jordan's skill that she's doing here her
piked double arabian with a half out and
showing how impressive it is that
there's so much energy involved
in this clip we're looking at now
three-time olympian sam mccoolick
performing
a casamanzu vault with one and a half
twists
vault is just so much fun there's so
many crazy physics things going on look
at that springboard some of his momentum
has transferred into the springboard he
does only about a half rotation before
he's fully upright
in the next half rotation of his flip he
does two and a half twists and then in
the last
half rotation he flails his arms out and
he only does a half turn so you can see
how much of an impact it is to have your
arms in tight
it's really hard to to stick the landing
on vaults especially coming from the
heights and
and coming in with the power that these
gymnasts have we can do some
calculations
to show just what kinds of forces sam is
experiencing
upon impact at this very moment sam is
at his max downward velocity
and then when he lands he'll come to a
standstill he'll have zero
translational velocity in the y
direction and he'll
only be moving sort of side to side to
get his balance
so if we can measure the time it takes
for him to decelerate and land
so his acceleration is his change in
velocity
over that time this is his average
acceleration it will be higher at points
and lower points
um is 6.8 meters per second
over you know 1 8 a second
so this is equal to
54.4
meters per second squared and in
languages of
gravity that's about
5.5 g's that's you know what you
experience
on really fast roller coasters watching
these clips with a particular
eye for the physics has been really
really interesting because
it's sort of brought me back into trying
to feel how my body interacts with the
equipment in different ways and
try to re-understand why that was
happening so looking through this lens
of physics has been
particularly rewarding